Latinoamérica es, tal vez, la región con
menos ambición militar del mundo…
sus gobiernos gastan relativamente poco en
defensa y en general, salvo alguna excepción,
eso de crear grandes, modernos y poderosos
ejércitos, no es una prioridad.
A pesar de ello, el tema de las Fuerzas Armadas
ha sido durante años, en esta región, un
tema controvertido, muy controvertido.
Y…
No es para menos, la segunda mitad del s.XX
no fue precisamente un tiempo tranquilo para
Latinoamérica.
Durante todo este periodo de tiempo y especialmente
en los años 60 y 70, esta región fue uno
de los territorios de todo el mundo más afectados
por la fuerza militar.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Los que nos estáis viendo desde allí, lo
sabéis bien.
En estos años prácticamente todos los países
de la región participaron en lo que se convirtió
en una especie de macabra tradición formada
por golpes de estado, juntas militares y,
por supuesto, mucha represión.
Echemos un vistazo por ejemplo a 1978.
En ese año, entre otros países, atentos,
Argentina, Bolivia, Brasil, Chile, Ecuador,
Paraguay, Perú, Cuba, Nicaragua, Honduras,
El Salvador, Panamá e incluso el pacífico
Uruguay estaban bajo dictaduras militares.
Y perdonadme si me he dejado alguno…
cómo veis la lista fue larga, demasiado larga.
(Y sí, España también sufrió durante 40
años una dictadura militar, aquí lecciones
históricas, ninguna).
El caso es que todo esto, era algo tan exagerado
que hasta en los cómics de Tintín se asociaba
a Latinoamérica con dictaduras militares.
Dictaduras de todos los colores: de izquierdas,
de derechas, pro-EEUU, anti-EEUU, más duras,
más blandas… pero todas con un elemento
común: la represión.
Y sí, en el marco de la guerra fría y la
lucha de bloques, muchas de estas dictaduras
fueron apoyadas por Estados Unidos en el marco
de lo que se conoció como la Operación Cóndor.
(Se conoce como Operación Cóndor, un siniestro
plan de inteligencia y colaboración entre
las dictaduras militares de la Argentina de
Videla, el Chile de Pinochet, el Paraguay
de Alfredo Stroessner, el Brasil de Joao Figueiredo
y el Uruguay de Bordaberry.
Todo con el apoyo de la CIA para lograr un
objetivo: perseguir y aniquilar a la oposición
política, especialmente a los grupos de izquierdas
apoyados por el régimen soviético.)
Claro que… no penséis que las dictaduras
con el otro color político fueron mejores,
para nada….
El caso, amigos, es que con este historia
no es es difícil imaginarse porque el tema
de las Fuerzas Armadas ha sido un tema tan
controvertido.
Pero bien, han pasado más de 30 años desde
este oscuro periodo… y en este vídeo queremos
responder a varias preguntas.
¿Cual es el estado de los ejércitos actualmente
en Latinoamérica?¿Qué funciones tienen?¿Podríamos
llegar a considerar una gran unión militar?
Veámoslo.
EJÉRCITOS EN LATINOAMÉRICA
Antes de empezar, y como curiosidad amigos,
os hago una pregunta:
¿Cuáles pensáis que son los ejércitos
más fuertes, más poderosos de Latinoamérica?
(Bueno, esto siempre bastante subjetivo, pero
según el Global FirePower Index 2017, un
indicador que trata de medir con diferentes
parámetros - como armamento o capacidades
logísticas - que ejércitos son más poderosos,
este el top 5 latinoaméricano.
En primer lugar, seguro que no os sorprende,
Brasil, el gran coloso regional.
Le siguen por este orden, Mexico, Argentina,
Perú y Colombia.)
Ahora bien, más allá de esta curiosidad,
lo cierto es que Latinoamérica es la región
que menos presupuesto dedica a defensa.
En 2016 poco más del 1% de su PIB, unos 67.000
millones de dólares.
Esto supone un nivel de gasto mucho más bajo
que la media del resto del mundo, pero es
que, además, los ejércitos latinoamericanos
tienden a tener un número de soldados bastante
alto.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en total la
región tiene algo más de 1.730.000 soldados.…
lo que al final provoca que sean ejércitos
poco modernos y con bastantes problemas de
operatividad.
Fijemos en el ejército más importante, el
brasileño.
(Brasil se gasta cada año 23.700 millones…
parece mucho ¿verdad?
El problema es que tiene más 340.000 soldados,
con lo que las tres cuartas partes del presupuesto
van a parar a salarios y pensiones.
Sí a esto le añadimos los aprovisionamientos
básicos, pues…
el dinero que queda para equipo es muy, muy
reducido.)
Y en el resto de Latinoamérica los ratios
son similares… de media el 70% del gasto
se va a parar directamente a salarios….
En otras palabras, los ejércitos latinoamericanos
por lo general tienen muchos soldados y pocos
equipos…
algo que directamente está relacionado con
su naturaleza.
Atentos.
MIRANDO HACIA DENTRO
Como hemos visto, amigos, si hablamos de ejércitos,
guerras y conflictos entre países, podemos
decir que Latinoamérica es una de las regiones
más pacíficas de todo el mundo.
El último conflicto armado se produjo ni
más ni menos que en 1994 en lo que se conoció
como la Guerra del Cenepa que enfrentó a
Ecuador y Perú…
aunque ni siquiera hubo una declaración de
guerra formal.
Desde entonces se ha impuesto una tendencia
que ha convertido a Latinoamérica en todo
un referente mundial:
(cada vez que hay una conflicto entre países,
en vez de amenazar a la otra parte con bombas
y cañones, en Latinoamérica se prefiere
recurrir al arbitraje internacional y a las
cortes internacionales de justicia).
Es lo que actualmente, por ejemplo, está
ocurriendo con el conflicto entre Bolivia
y Chile por la salida al mar, un conflicto
que se está resolviendo en la Corte Internacional
de Justicia de La Haya.
“Bolivia presenta réplica en la demanda
contra Chile en la Corte de La Haya por acceso
al mar”.
BBC
Sin embargo…
A nivel interno las cosas cambian por completo.
Podríamos decir, que Latinoamérica tiene
el récord de ser al mismo tiempo la región
más pacífica y también la más violenta….
No, tranquilos, no he perdido la cabeza.
Me explico, entre países no hay ninguna amenaza
seria de guerra… pero si hablamos la violencia,
eso es otra cosa.
Mirad.
“En Latinoamérica vive el 8% de la población
mundial, pero se concentra el 33% de los homicidios.
De las 50 ciudades más violentas del mundo
en 2016, 42 se encuentra en Latinoamérica”.
ARTURO C.
SOTOMAYOR, profesor en el Departamento de
Ciencia Política y Geografía de la University
of Texas”.
Así que… como parece que los “enemigos”
están en casa, los militares latinoamericanos
se centran sobre todo en labores dentro de
casa…
como por ejemplo enfrentarse a guerrillas,
narcotraficantes o hacer frente a la violencia
general.
De hecho, en la región cada vez es más común
que los militares sustituyan a los policías
en muchas tareas de seguridad y vigilancia.
Y aquí el problema, amigos, es que la evidencia
muestro que los a soldados esto de ejercer
de policías no se les da precisamente bien.
LA SOLUCIÓN INSUFICIENTE
Frente a lo que podríamos pensar a primera
vista, las tasas de criminalidad en Brasil
o México, lejos de reducirse, han aumentado
desde que los soldados participan en tarea
de seguridad ciudadana..
De hecho, en las 5 ciudades más peligrosas
del mundo, Caracas, Acapulco, San Pedro Sula,
Distrito Central y Victoria, hay presencia
militar.
Y eso no es todo.
(Los casos de abusos de poder, detenciones
extrajudiciales o víctimas colaterales también
se han incrementado con la presencia militar,
lo que además favorece y alimenta una cultura
de la violencia, que desgraciadamente hoy
está demasiado extendida en toda la región.)
El problema es que los soldados son fuerzas
entrenadas para la guerra y para eliminar
al enemigo, no para imponer el orden y el
estado de derecho.
Para conseguir esto lo que se necesitan son
detectives, tribunales y jueces, policías
de proximidad, colaboración ciudadana, etcétera,
etcétera.
Podemos echar un vistazo a lo que ha ocurrido,
por ejemplo, en México.
(Nada más llegar al poder, en diciembre de
2006, Felipe Calderón declaró la guerra
contra las drogas y puso al ejército a pie
de calle.
Desde entonces no solo no se ha reducido el
tráfico de narcóticos, sino que la tasa
de homicidios se llegó a triplicar.)
El ejército, simplemente no es suficiente.
En casos muy graves puede echar una mano pero
no puede llevar la dirección de los asuntos
internos porque, simplemente no funciona.
Sí, sé que la policía corrupta es una problema,
pero no se arregla simplemente recurriendo
al ejército.
Algo que por cierto, tiene, además, otros
dos grandes problemas:
El primero el riesgo político.
Fijaos en estas palabras:
“Las fuerzas armadas de América Latina
deben ser antiimperialistas” Evo Morales.
¿Qué queréis que os diga?
A mi esto de ver a políticos utilizando a
los militares para defender sus ideas políticas,
sean las que sean, me parece algo muy, muy
peligroso.
Pensad que el uso del poder de la fuerza siempre
será tentador…
Es lo que ha ocurrido, por ejemplo, en Venezuela,
donde las Fuerzas Armadas se han convertido
en algo así-como la Guardia Pretoriana del
régimen bolivariano de Nicolás Maduro.
Sí, eso de tener a las Fuerzas Armadas mirando
para dentro…
no suele deparar cosas buenas.
Y por si no fuese suficiente también está
el problema de la corrupción.
Veréis, la industria militar es una industria
opaca y de grandes contratos…
dos ingredientes básicos de la corrupción.
Atentos, a lo que ocurrió en 2010 en la República
Dominicana:
“En 2010 un gran escándalo de corrupción
afectó a las Fuerzas Armadas dominicanas
por la compra fraudulenta de 8 aviones Súper
Tucanos a la empresa brasileña Embraer.
Se sospecha que 87 millones de dólares se
quedaron en manos de miembros de la alta jerarquía
política y militar del país”.LILIAN BOBEA,
profesora en la Bentley University de Massachusetts.
Y es solo un ejemplo, ni siquiera el más
importante.
Pues bien, teniendo todo este cuenta, ¿no
sería bueno pensar en una gran alianza militar?
¿UNA OTAN LATINOAMÉRICANA?
Me vais a permitir que ponga sobre la mesa
una idea que tal vez os pueda parecer un pelín
descabellada
Visto lo visto, ¿No sería bueno pensar en
construir una gran alianza militar?
Un gran alianza en la que los diferentes países
se organizaran y aportaran diferentes unidades
y cuerpos para diferentes tareas.
(De esta forma cada país podría concentrar
una buena parte de su presupuesto militar
en crear un ejército bien equipado que integrado
con el resto de ejércitos de los demás países
creasen una fuerza operativa y con capacidad
de despliegue rápido)
Esto, amigos, tendría muchas ventajas:
se reduciría la influencia de los militares
en el poder político,
se garantizaría la soberanía de todos los
países
Y además, en caso de ser necesario, por ejemplo
ante catástrofes naturales, los países latinoamericanos
contarían con un ejército capaz de desplegarse
rápido y con altos niveles de operatividad.
Además, empujaría la necesaria integración
latinoaméricana y el propio papel de este
región en el mundo.
Pero, sobre todo, amigos, liberaría muchos
recursos, tanto económicos como humanos,
para impulsar tareas de seguridad ciudadana
capaces de reducir las altísimas tasas de
violencia...
Qué hoy por hoy, son sin lugar a dudas, uno
de los grandes frenos para el despegue definitivo
de la región.
Ojo, en cierto modo la Unión Europea está
tratando de hacer algo similar…
así que puede que suene descabellado… pero
no tanto.
Al fin y al cabo Costa Rica hace décadas
que suprimió su ejercito y los resultados
en términos de seguridad han sido mejores
que los de sus vecinos.
Se dice amigos, lo hemos visto aquí en VisualPolitik,
que el siglo XXI va a ser el siglo de la India,
de China y en general de Asia; y yo me pregunto
¿por qué no el siglo de Latinoamérica?
Ahora turno para ti, ¿Estarías a favor de
una gran unión militar latinoamericana?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Me parece, amigos, que esta vez el debate
va a estar caliente.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo échanos una mano
y compártelo con tus amigos, dale a like
y por supuesto, si no lo has hecho, no olvides
suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Por cierto, antes de irte, una noticia:
el próximo viernes 24 de noviembre y también
el sábado 25, vamos a estar en León con
nuestros amigos de Students For Liberty.
Hablaremos sobre globalización y casos de
éxito.
En la descripción os dejamos más detalles.
Si podéis, no dudéis en pasaros.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.